♪ (music) ♪
I'm Vijay.
Today I'll be talking to you
or hopefully convincing you
that when we try to apply
machine learning to solving problems,
that we should really be thinking
about designing search spaces
over solutions to those problems.
And then we can use
automated machine-learning techniques
in order to evaluate our ideas
much more efficiently.
I think a big reason
why a lot of us are here today
is due to the incredible impact
that machine-learning
can have on practical problems.
Two often cited reasons for this
is that we have increasing amounts
of compute capability
and access to data to train on.
But I think one other aspect
is all of you-- right?
There's so many more people involved
in machine-learning today
that are contributing
and publishing ideas.
So ThisCraft tries to put this
into perspective by measuring
how many machine learning papers
are published on Arxiv
every year since 2009,
and plotting that against
a Moore's Law exponential growth curve.
As you can see here,
we've been keeping up with Moore's Law
2x every two years very, very well.
And this is demonstrating just
how many new ideas
are being developed in the field.
This is a great thing, right?
So, one concrete way of looking at this
is that in the field of computer vision,
we've seen Top 1 imaging accuracy
start from something like in the 50% range
from the AlexNet architecture,
which, by the way, revolutionized
the field of image classification.
And every year we've been just
getting better and better up until 2017.
Now, these improvements haven't come
just because we've been training
bigger models, right?
These improvements have also come
from the fact
that we have lots of great ideas, right?
Things like batch normalization,
residual or skip connections,
and various regularization techniques.
Now, each of these points,
like Jeff mentioned earlier,
is the result of years of research effort.
And we build on each other's ideas.
But one of the challenging things
is how do we keep up with so much,
so many ideas that are being produced?
And I also want you
to zoom-in a little bit
in terms of the complexity
of some of these models.
So we are going to zoom-in a little bit
on InceptionV4 here
and look at the kind of idea
that's embedded inside there.
These are two convolutional cell modules
within the Inception-V4 architecture.
Every single one of these arrows
and operations and even the numbers
was designed by a human.
Somebody wrote some code
in order to specify
all of these little details.
Now, there are high-level reasons
why this kind of architecture
might make sense,
but our theory doesn't really explain
with so much certainty
how every detail seems to matter.
And, as a field, I think
we're definitely working on trying
to improve the theory behind this.
But for many of us, we're just happy
to use this kind of complexity
out of the box, if we can,
because it really helps to solve problems.
Now this isn't too surprising-- we know
that because machine-learning
has had such an impact on real products
that we are going to be
willing to use
anything we possibly can.
And even if we don't understand
all the little, minor details,
as long as it solves our problems well
and hopefully, are understandable.
So, given all these ideas,
how can we harness this explosion
of ideas much more efficiently?
So let's step back and kind of ask
a few questions that we might've heard
when we were just trying
to train machine-learning models.
These are simple questions,
but hard questions.
Like, "What learning rate should I apply
for my optimization?"
Or, if I am training
a Deep Neural Network model,
"What dropout rate should I apply?"
How do we answer this question today?
I think we combine a few
different types of benefits.
One of them is
leveraging researcher intuition
and engineering intuition.
And what this means is that we start
with code or we ask our colleagues,
"Hey, what are good settings
for these fields?"
And if it were the case that there was
one setting that works for everybody,
we wouldn't even be looking
at these parameters.
But it does matter.
So then we move on
to some trial and error process.
We try a certain setting
and then we see
how well it works on our problem
and then we continue to iterate.
And I think the other aspect,
which is becoming more common, hopefully,
is increasing access to computing data
by which we can evaluate these ideas.
So this combination is really ripe
for automation, right?
And not surprisingly, this exists today.
It's called hyperparameter optimization
and in this kind of set up what we have
is a tuner that's giving out settings
for these hyperparameter settings.
We have a trainer
that trains our model our dataset,
and then tries to give some kind of signal
about how good those settings were.
So it might give a validation accuracy
of some value,
and the tuner can then learn
from this feedback to find better points
from the search space.
This is an existing big field
and there are existing systems
like those shown at the very bottom
that can help you to do this.
But now, let's kind of ask a few more
complicated questions
or detailed questions
that I think people do
often ask as well.
"Why do you use batch norm before relu?"
"I switched the order
and it seems to work better."
Or, if you're trying to train
a completely new model,
"Should I use one type of sub-architecture
or another type of sub-architecture?"
Now, if you think about it,
these questions aren't really that
different from hyperparameter settings.
So, if we think
of hyperparameter optimization
as searching over
a specific domain of ideas,
then it seems possible that maybe
we can actually treat the decisions
made in this type of model
as another form of searching
over a domain of ideas.
And we can therefore think
about de-emphasizing any specific decision
that we make in our architectures,
and, instead, think about the search space
of ideas that we might have.
So let's take a concrete example
of a search space design
that my colleague Derek did,
where he tried to design
a search space for a convolutional cell.
I'll walk you through
how you might design such a search space.
So the first question is--
you have to get your inputs.
So we might say, you have access
to your previous input,
and if you want to have support
for things like skip connections,
you might have
the previous-previous input.
So the first job in the search space
is to define which inputs
I am going to select.
And then, once you have
those inputs selected,
you want to then to figure out
what operation should I apply
to each of those inputs
before summing them together.
So I might select something
like 3x3 convolution,
or 3x3 max pooling and then combine
those operations together.
Now, we can then recursively
turn that crank
and apply it several more times,
where we use, maybe, different operations
for different inputs.
And you can even use
the intermediate outputs
of previous decisions in our search.
And then, finally, you take
all of your outputs, that are unused,
and you can catenate them together.
And that is your convolutional cell.
And then finally, if you want to build
your whole model just like ResNet,
you might stack that same model
several times.
Now, I want to point out
that this is just one example.
Like one point
from the search space of ideas.
There are a billion possible ways
that you can construct a cell like this
in the search space.
by changing the set of operations
you have on your list,
the kind of ways that the connections
can be made, and so forth.
So, now, we've defined our search space,
we kind of go back to that type
of parameter-tuning type system
where we have
a program generator on the left
that generates samples
from this search space.
We then train and evaluate
on the task at hand,
and often time it's going
to be a proxy task.
And then we iterate to quickly find
what are the best programs
from our search space.
And the system on the left--
this program generator--
can optionally learn from feedback.
So it might use something like
reinforcement learning,
evolutionary algorithms,
or even random search
can work well in certain situations.
So we did this type of approach.
We took this convolutional cell,
we trained it on a proxy task,
such as Cifar10
for a small number of epochs
to make quick progress
on the evaluation of an idea.
And then we took the best candidate-cells
that we found from that search.
We enlarged in terms of number of filters
and number of times we've stacked it,
and we applied that
to the ImageNet dataset.
And these are two cells
found from that search.
If you then look at the results
of applying those,
you'll see that we were actually able
to do better than the existing state
of the art models,
in terms of Top-1 accuracy.
Now, this effort was an example
where we took a model
where decisions were pretty complex
and we, honestly, found
another complex model that was better.
But next, I'll show you an example
where we can use this general technique
to find even more interpretable outputs.
So, let's look
at optimization update rules.
Most of you are, probably, familiar
with stochastic gradient descent,
and the update rule is shown on the left
where you take the gradient
and you multiply it by the learning rate
and that's your way to delta.
And then we have
more advanced optimization update rules,
like Adam, and these can be expressed
fairly concisely just by being given
things like the moving average
of the gradient, and so forth.
But we really only have like a handful
of this type of optimization update rules
that we're typically applying
for deep learning, for example.
What if we, instead, treat
these update equation rules
as parts of a larger search space?
And so, you can take these expressions
and turn them
into a kind of a data flow craft
that describes the update rule.
By using a small set
of primitive operations
and ways of combining them,
we can express these two update rules
using this simple tree,
but also a lot of other ideas.
And so you can then turn this crank
on this new search space,
and try to find
a better optimization update rule.
So, my colleagues Irwan and Barret
ran this experiment,
where they took
a fixed convolutional model
and tried to search
over the optimization rules.
And they found update equations
that did better than some of the others
I'd shown you on this particular task.
And one nice feature of this search space
is that the results
are much more interpretable.
If you look
аt the fourth update rule here,
it's taking the gradient
and multiplying it by some expression
that essentially says
that when the gradient
and the moving average of the gradient
agree in their direction,
then we should take a bigger step
in that direction.
And when they disagree,
that we should take a smaller step.
This is actually a form of momentum.
And so one thing we can get from this is--
maybe we should be designing search spaces
that have more notions of momentum encoded
within the search space of ideas.
We may be able to find
even better results.
So far I've focused on techniques
and search space ideas,
where we care about accuracy.
But what's great about searching
over many ideas
is that we might have the potential
to search over more than just accuracy.
So, for example, a lot of us care
about inference speed, right?
We want to take a model and deploy it
on real hardware, real mobile platform.
And very often we spend a lot of time
trying to figure out how to take one idea
and make it fast enough.
But what if you could, as part
of the search space of ideas,
find ones that balance both speed
and accuracy?
So we tried to do this experiment
where we included the run time
on a real mobile device as part
of this interloop of the evaluation.
So we tried to focus optimize on both--
accuracy, as well as inference speed.
And as this process goes on over time,
the program generator is able
to find faster models
while also figuring out how to make
those models even more accurate.
One interesting side effect of this
is that when you run searches over ideas,
the output is actually not just one model,
it's a culture of models
that implicitly encodes this tradeoff.
So, this kind of shows you
that we have points along the space
that provide a tradeoff
between inference speed
on the multi-platform,
and accuracy on the dataset
that we're trying to solve.
And so rather than
manually engineering the one point
that I really want get working,
I can get a result that maybe
can be deployed
on various types of platforms.
So I'll emphasize this
in maybe a slightly different way.
Which is that we could define
a search space of ideas
in TensorFlow and through this automatic
machine-learning process,
we can get models
that have a guaranteed runtime
performance target
on a TargetPlatform device.
One of the nice things
about having an integrated ecosystem
like TensorFlow is that you can just
use the libraries that convert
from program to program,
so that you can get
this end to end pipeline
working well together.
There is no manual work required
to specifically tune a model.
So, let me conclude by returning
to this process of evaluating ideas
in this world, where we're trying
to explore different ideas.
The first is that we design search spaces
to try to test out a large set
of possible ideas.
Now, note that when we designed
the search space,
that required human intuition.
There is still a need for human ingenuity
as part of this process.
So, designing the search space properly,
takes a lot of effort
but at least it allows you to evaluate
many more ideas much more quickly.
And when it comes to trial-and-error,
we had to start thinking about
how software should be changed,
so that we can permit
this type of search process.
So, for example, I think many of us
have probably written scripts where
you take things like learning rate
and dropout rate as command-line flags.
What if you wanted to test out
much more deeper ideas in your programs?
How do you design it such
that it's much more tunable
at all levels of your program?
I think this is a big question
for us to tackle.
And lastly, we think these ideas
will become increasingly relevant
as many of you get access to more and more
computation capabilities,
such as things like TPU pods
Imagine a world
where all you have to do
is take your idea,
submit it to an idea bank,
and you have some like pod of TPUs
crunching overnight, trying to figure out
which solutions or ideas are the best.
And then waking up in the morning
and it telling you,
"these were the good ideas,
these were the bad ideas," and so forth.
I think part of the reason
this excites me
is that automatic machine-learning
can keep these machines
much more busy than we can.
We have to sleep, but machines
can keep on turning 24/7.
So, with that, thanks for listening!
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪